ساعه انتظار طويله احساسها اشبه بايام
لكنها ختمت اسبوعها الاول بالفعل فالزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا دخل يومه
السابع وكافه الضحايا في ميزان العالقين
باتت الراجحه حاليا متخطيه عتبه الثلاثين
الف قتيل
سبعه ايام قادمه وتزداد سوادا مع توقعات
بارتفاع اعداد القتلى لنحو الضعف لكن كيف
بدات
زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه ضرب على بعد 17 كيلو
مترا قرب غازي عنتاب في الساعه الرابعه
وسبعه عشره دقيقه بالتوقيت المحلي تلاه
زلزال اخر واكثر من 650 هزه ارتداديه وفق
مسؤولين اتراك حل مدمرا في عشر ولايات
تركيه وخمس محافظات سوريه شملت حلب وادلب
عدد القتلى تخطى 7500 شخص في البلدين مع
استمرار معارك البحث عن ناجين واعلن
الرئيس التركي حاله الطوارئ بالولايات
العشر المتضرره لثلاثه اشهر لافتا الى
تضرر حوالي 13 مليون وخمسمائه الف شخص
و11000 مبنى
ثالث ايام الكارثه شهد تحذيرا من اغلاق
النافذه الذهبيه للعثور على ناجين مع وصول
عدد القتلى الى اكثر من تسعه الاف وستمائه
قتيل
بعدها بيوم عداد الضحايا دقه عتبه العشرين
الفا مع استمرار عمليه البحث والانقاذ كما
سجل التاسع من فبراير وصول اول قافله
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر معبر باب
الهوى اجمالي عدد القتلى واصل ارتفاعه الى
اكثر من 22,000 بالاضافه 82 الف مصاب
حقائق وقاده اردوغان للاعتراف ببطء
استجابه السلطات التركيه للزلازل الجنوبيه
البلاد
مع دخول الكارثه يومها السادس اعلن مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري وقفه عمليات الانقاذ
لتبدا عمليات انتشال الضحايا العالقين تحت
الانقاض اما في تركيا فتواصلت عمليات
البحث مسجله معجزه قليله
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ثلاثه وعشرين مليون شخص تاثر
بالكارثه موت واصابات وتشريد جروح توازي
بعمقها شقوقا في مبان شبه صامده وطرقات
متقطعه